-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
This is "Late Night."
How was everybody's
last two weeks?
Wonderful!
Mine were, too.
Let's get to the news.
Congress returned today
after a two-week recess.
"Not much.
Just hung out,"
said Matt Gaetz,
before anyone could talk.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz
used the cash transfer
app Venmo
to send an accused
sex trafficker $900,
who then paid three young wome
for "tuition and school,"
which is a pretty weak attempt
to cover your tracks.
That's like leaving your walle
at a crime scene,
but wiping
your fingerprints off it.
The House Ethics Committee
announced Friday
it will launch an investigatio
into Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz
over allegations that he
"may have engaged
in sexual misconduct
and/or illicit drug use,
shared inappropriate image
or videos on the House floor
misused state
identification records,
converted campaign funds
to personal use,
and/or accepted a bribe,
improper gratuity,
or impermissible gift,"
or as Republicans call it,
running for reelection.
[ Laughter ]
New York City
mayoral candidate Andrew Yan
marked National Pet Day
yesterday
by tweeting that his family ha
to give away their dog
after one of his sons
became allergic.
Well, I can't wait to see what
he posts for Mother's Day.
[ Laughter ]
He's the new Scollins.
He's ruining days.
[ Laughter ]
Two weeks off,
I felt like days were safe
[ Laughter ]
Britain's Prince Harry
is reportedly set
to travel back to the UK
this week
for his grandfather
Prince Philip's funeral.
Apparently, as a latch-ditch
effort to revive him.
[ As Philip ]
Why, you little piece of -
[ Laughter ]
I don't know
if we should've done that
on a night John Oliver's
going to be on.
Because he's probably
pretty beat up about it all.
[ Laughter ]
After recently calling on hi
supporters to boycott Coca-Col
and other companies
that criticized
Georgia's new voting law,
former President Trump
was recently photographed
with a bottle of Diet Coke
and, somewhere out there,
Robert Mueller gently pumped
his fist and whispered --
[ As Mueller ]
Got 'im.
The Brewers and Miller Lit
are now selling candles,
which include scents
such as Dive Bar,
Beer Garden, and Game Day.
Of course, their beer
will remain unscented.
[ Laughter ]
According to reports,
a single person showed up
to a so-called
white lives matter march
and rally on Sunday in New York.
So, less of a rally
and more of someone angril
going for a walk.
Karen wrote that joke
and I like when Karen
writes jokes about Karens.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a documentar
streaming service announce
over the weekend that it's
looking for three people
to binge-watch 24 hours
of true crime documentaries.
Though, I'll be more impressed
if you can find
three people who aren't.
And that was the monologue
everybody.